comment allez vous est ce que tout le
monde va bien je m'en fous évidemment
aujourd'hui nouveau savourer dit c'est
le 416 y aime ou qu'on fait mais j'ai
toujours autant de plaisir à les faire
alors j'espère que vous aussi
auquel cas c'est bien bon c'est bien
beau aujourd'hui c'est vrai dit assez
cool qui s'appelle of course
that's cls moi faire le mec avec un
accent c'est le seul moment de l'année
où je parle anglais c'est quand je dis
le nom dans ce raid en vidéo c'est le
seul moment se sevrer dit c'est simple
c'est oui ce truc existe voilà alors ça
peut être des objets des services d un
peu de tout ça quoi plein de trucs dont
vous ignoriez l'existence et connaître
l'existence de ces trucs va soit vous
faire un bien fou soit ne rien changer
oh là là mais comment taire n'apporte
rien professional tags
ah oui ça j'avais vu c'est incroyable
c'est des mecs je crois c'est des mecs
qui jouent à chat mais à un niveau
olympique voyez je regardais il ya un
petit parcours on peut passer au dessus
ou en dessous met à l'amendé un mec
comme dans la cour de récré en 5e quoi
c'est incroyable mais c'est
impressionnant les mecs sont vraiment
chaud ils volent quoi quasiment et c'est
vraiment un chat un chat ça ça me tue ya
quand même 20 mecs sur la planète ou
quand il était petit qui passaient leur
temps à jouer à chat leur mère leur
disais mais arrête
l'idée truc apprend des choses ce sera
plus utile et elle avait tort aux
caisses et babolat avait tort
c'est devenu la profession du mec voir
groupe comme c'est terrible pour ces
mamans à les hashtag un petit soutien
pour les mères qui avaient tort de dire
à leurs enfants ne pas jouer à chat
voilà s'élancer en obligé à chaque vidéo
aurait dû tourner ça on y va batterie
faible
ne vous en faites par meurt avec moi est
une application tu peux utiliser que
quand tu as 5 % de batterie où l'on
mourait ensemble dans un chat sur le
chemin de la paix de la déconnexion
cheveux je veux tout de suite
alors parce que j'ai 80 % batterie je
peux pas y aller c'est d'exclusion sao
vous rendez compte c'est réservé à
l'élite à ceux qui sont suffisamment
calme dans leur vie pour accepter de
passer sous les 20% de batteries sont
rechargées c'est incroyable c'est
l'élite de l'élite c'est là-dessus qu'il
faut rencontrer votre copain à votre
copine le quitte un jour une banane qui
contient plusieurs banane de murté
différentes comme ça tu peux les manger
plusieurs jours d'affilée et elles
seront toujours mur pareil waouh je
suivrai ce qu'il veut il l'a fait et lui
sa maman elle avait raison quand elle
lui disait d'arrêter de jouer à chat et
ces coréens toujours toujours les bonnes
idées ces coréens bravo bravo à vous si
vous êtes coréen si vous n'êtes pas
coréen dommages à venir une table de
nuit qui sert d'armes de self défense
mais c'est glauque mais vous êtes fous
et d'un autre côté je la veux un peu je
suis partagé la est-ce que je viens trop
par à cause des serait d'horreur qui se
passe pour 20 dollars un centre de
réhabilitation dans l'oregon inscrira le
nom de votre ex sur un saut mots avant
de le donner à manger à un ours c'est
nul comme bonjour ans voit bonhomme
nantes a fait marquer son nom sur un
saumon mec terme à la vengeance aller
c'est quoi le but
bon au moins tu te venge en horizon il
ya un conte instar de quelqu'un qui fait
des fuck à des poissons non à la cu huy
lazer oui un rubik's cube qui s'ouvre
comme un coffre aux trésors
il s'ouvre uniquement quand tu l'a
résolu incroyable génial vous n'avez pas
d'idée de cadeau de noël voilà si vous
avez un fan de rubik's cube autour vous
lui offrez ça c'est extraordinaire
vraiment insu un tube qui évite les
distractions de notre téléphone pendant
qu'on parle aurait des téléphones pour
nous aider puis ils nous parlent asie
alors on crée un truc pour pas que ça
nous parasites c'est génial écoutez moi
bien moi et l'intégralité de mes amis
avons besoin de cet outil
d'accord je vais trouver je vais
l'offrir à un pote qui est trop sur son
thème il fera me détestais ça plus mon
pote à prévoir une machine inutile très
avancé ok des qui pousse à interrupteur
il ya un truc qui vient les remettre à
leur place initiale
si chaque mech j'éprouve de la sympathie
envers le truc là qui vient appuyer sur
les boutons c'est gervais problème je le
trouve adorable j'ai envie que soit mon
ami j'ai un vrai problème peut-être que
je me sente très seule en hiver un
imperméable pour basket créons des
chaussures pour nous protéger de la
pluie et du vent
cris yoann imperméable pour protéger les
chaussures de la pluie et du vent
sinon quoi il pleut mais juste des
chaussures moins onéreuse je sais pas ça
me tue ce truc de créer des inventions
pour combler un blème qu'a eue avec une
invention précédentes c'est bizarre une
paroi de douche avec des poches pour vos
appareils électroniques
non ça c'est nord c'est le seul moment
qui nous reste est loin des écrans
c'était la douche je ne veux pas de ça
ça dégage il y à un jeu télé japonais ça
commence bien
où il cherche quelque chose dans une
pièce avec du chocolat et les parties
on doit le trouver je veux voir
et l école à youtube heure là haut
pourquoi ne pas copier encore ce concept
parce qu'il faut du talent pour faire le
truc en chocolat ailleurs imaginer
mourir dans cette ambulance ayant pour
thème les minions tu meures et
susciterait et j'irai me tuer moi même
dans l'ambulance
c'est horrible je me démerde une
ambulance à thème c'est juste glos n'a
pas envie d'être des putains de minions
quoi quand et dans le mal non ça peut
être pas mal un thème un peu cool mais
là c'est un thème que tu te mange tout
le temps promo partout en partenaire de
toutes les marques et tous tu vas au
cinéma aucune pub pour les minions
d'achat des ménages
hop une collab avec les minions tumeurs
de montesquieu le dernier truc que tu
vois c'est un mignon c'est horrible je
suis totalement contre cette idée de
mettre des thèmes dans les ambulances
l'océan atlantique a été notée 3,9 sur
google maps ou tu peux noter l'océan 3,7
dur avec les océans plus tard ils font
ce qu'ils peuvent aller acheter qu'une
petite pensée pour le tour atlantica non
mais c'est vrai quoi et puis j'ai
remarqué un truc c'est que souvent au
collège au contrôle celui que j'ai
oublié c'était l'océan atlantique
j'arrivais pas à franchement on est
ingrat cinq pièces d'un cent tort qu'ils
vont sur tes doigts pour faire un
centaure complet pour plusieurs minutes
de fun non non le seul jouet accepté
comme ça avec les doigts c'est le
fingerskate tous les autres c'est soit
possible quelqu'un à payer pour faire la
promo de son chien promo c'est quoi
l'histoire car derrière ça c'est quoi le
but c'est genre ton chien il regarde un
peu les commentaires et les et les lacs
et s'il n'y a pas assez de là qu'il est
restée aveugle et toi tu veux pas qu'ils
furent donc tu paies pour art des lacs
je comprends pas la suite la plus
attendue uno dos
servat c'est la même carte ils ont juste
mis des deux dessus et vous savez quoi
malgré tout je l'achète je l'achète
quand même merde c'est la suite du
hainaut plus tard rigole pas avec ça
allait on l'achète et on se tait c'est
tout the bread storage à lienemann
charte
alors ça c'est la flemme de lire ça je
suis désolé flemme de lire c'est bien ça
me fait penser c'est chez vous quand
j'aime pas c'est exactement soit malade
j'avais vu avant de faire la vidéo le
case du travail vous inviter à regarder
c'est vrai je suis ça m'a un peu trop
mal je suis j'aime plus trop ce format
pas fanboy ce format aa quoi c'est
horrible un hôtel qui coûte 1 $ par nuit
par contre ils ont le droit de live
stream tout ton séjour sur leur chaîne
youtube
c'est tellement du voyeurisme nous on
aide les gens qui ont peu de moyens mais
on filme toute leur vie
privé en échange les gars calmez vous
mon université a créé un jour qui
s'appelle venez en tracteur est-ce que
du coup si t'as pas de tracteur tu es
obligé d'en louer un
sinon tu te fais boulaye on se moque de
toi lui par exemple lui j'ai
l'impression que tu as pas de facteur
viii à ça j'avais vu ça ça doit vraiment
être cool c'est une touche entre ictu
branche en usb et tu frappes et ça fait
vraiment comme steve appuyez sur entrée
sur ton clavier c'est sympa waouh
incroyable ça une imprimante genre
humain quoi putain c'est dingue je me
renseigne pour yoko là cet instrument
boisset des chaussures pour pas qu'on
puisse suivre la direction tu es en
train de te pas les empreintes des
leçons dans le sens inverse du coup
assez horrible c'était des gens très mal
intentionnés ont pris beaucoup de leur
temps pour créer un outil de ce genre
quoi pour vraiment faire encore plus de
choses mal intentionnés c'est terrible
non me dis pas que c'est ce que je pense
[Musique]
fois à tous elle existe avouez qu'on
avait dix ans on a tout pété un câble
devant taxi quand il se passe exactement
ça danse ça existe ça existe pour de
vrai mec incroyable vient le moment où
tu passes en prison après une fois que
tu te fais contrôler c'est incroyable ce
toboggan est alimenté en eau pour pas
brûler les enfants quand il fait chaud
waouh on n'est plus un enfant donc on
s'en fout un anglais saute d'une plate
forme en saut à l'élastique juste pour
tremper son biscuit dans son thé c'est
quoi ces conneries
ok
c'est le guinness ben brik
non
[Musique]
tant d'énergie pour un truc sic on
j'adore mais d'un autre côté je peux pas
je peux pas m'empêcher de me dire putain
mais si cette énergie on l'a consacré un
truc vraiment utile genre il se
passerait quoi c'est bizarre comme
réflexion chez ba une horloge de 24
heures non ça c'est dans sa section non
moi je vais m'énerver a au bout d'un
moment on n'est plus capable de lire 6 7
8 9
oui 2 au lieu de 10 ouais c'est bien en
fait à eelv a parfaitement rentré dans
ma collection de chameau bipied en train
de dunker noiseau momifiée et now c'est
trop pour aujourd'hui
oh moi aussi je veux faire de la pêche à
leyment comme celle thibault est tous là
c'est tellement glauque septembre est
une bouteille d'eau ah ouais eau est une
capsule qui retire de l'équation le
plastique des bouteilles en plastique
créé par le laboratoire skipping web os
est créé à partir d'algues marron donc
c'est 100% biodégradable putain mais du
coup quand tu l'achètes s'est vendu dans
quoi boîtes en plastique n'ont pas
forcément mais je trouve ça cool en tout
cas de voir ça ça montre qu'il ya
vraiment des labos là qu'ils recherchent
activement une matière où des solutions
pour remplacer les emballages plastiques
soit un vrai putain de fléaux place est
très fort quand même ce qu'on vient de
voir c'est très très fort je trouve ça
incroyable
bon eh bien écoutez je crois qu'on
arrive au bout de ce vrai dit il était
sympa en fait c'est vraiment un sobre et
10 typique de résident ceux dans
lesquels tu découvre l'existence de
trucs très cool genre d'objets ou de
services voix et à linverse de trucs -
le cool
voilà une conclusion de blaye un bien
pourri sa vie d'axa prédit le disco j'ai
bien kiffé et franchement c'est je me
j'ai vraiment bloqué sur le la capsule
d'eau là parce que j'ai vu qu'il y avait
des marques là qui commençait à mettre
des emballages débuté en carton il m'a
dégoûté en plastique ce qui est génial
c'est très intéressant en fait en tout
cas ça fait plaisir de voir qu'il ya des
recherches vraiment qui sont faites et
que des fois ça amène à des résultats
comme la coiffe tout ça vraiment qu'on
voit c'est la petite note positive qui
m'a fait vraiment du bien vous recevrez
dit désolé c'est mon fils jean mistou
qu'un boeing en liant positif mais c'est
du tout qui m'a fait le plus plaisir là
dans ce mot est dit voilà ça bien sûr l
amp 40 retrouvé dans un lac par un
enfant évidemment allez je vous dis à
bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]